それでかっこいい 好かれる人
正しいかっこいい人になるための条件
まあ今ですね テーマに入ったな
まあ世間に貢献することです
世間に貢献する人は世間に好かれるんです
我々はもう世間で生きているんだから
何か世間にしてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでかっこいいんです
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
その生き方は羨ましく思われるんです
例えば 私の生き方がによって
いろんな人が助かっているならば
それが羨ましがられる生き方なんです
あの人は助かります あの人は役に立ちますよと
今は強引に怒鳴って脅さないと人の役に立つようなことをしないんですけど
まあ普通自然にそうやっちゃえば簡単でしょうに
あの 木曜日のね 勉強会で一人の質問がありましたけどね
まあもう親3人との面倒を見なくちゃいけないという質問でね
まあ二人がまあ年次障害にもなってしまって
だから一人の女の人がね
もう年取ってる  3人の面倒をまわって
もうこれ大変なことなんですけど
だからものすごく疲れて
いろいろ精神的に参ったりあったりしてね
私は言ったの それで別にいいんだよと
だから本人本当はそれ言ってないんですけど
本人の命が役に立ってるんですよ
それで十分です 私には映画を見る暇もないんだよとかね
昼寝する暇もないんだよとか
そんなごちゃごちゃ言わなくても
昼寝する暇もないんですと
なぜならば 自分が役に立っている
買い物に行ったっても
あっちこっちいろんな品物を見ながら
あれもいいな これもいいなとか
でも高いなとか そんな無駄な無駄に使う時間がないんです
認知障害になっているおばあさんとおじいさんが家にいるんだから
何するかわからないんだからね
帰ってくると家がもう燃えている可能性もあるんだからね
だから買い物行ってても
さささっと品物をだけ買って
さっともう戻ってこなくちゃいけない
それで人生はものすごく素晴らしいと思いますよ
クタクタ疲れるんだけど
その生き方は尊いんですよ
人の役に立っている だから我々一人一人
周りの役に立っている生き方をすれば
もうそれでもう完璧にかっこいいんです
外見はどうであっても
世間は役に立つ人を評価するんです
結局は人は最終的には外見では評価しません
役に立つ人は評価されますよ
延々と 貢献する人間になることは難しくありません
心は汚れることもなく
攻撃を受ける心配もなく
真のかっこいい人はこの世でもあの世でも成功を収めるのです
ということで ですから
生命の役に立つ生き方をする
それで話は終わりと その人にはもう攻撃は攻撃に心配する必要はないんです
誰かに足を引っ張られるとか
そんな心配も要りません
私の今の人気はすぐ消えるぞとか
もう若くてかっこいいんだと
人気ある人はもう年取るともうかっこ悪くなりますから
もう人気が消えますよ
だから安心して安定して
死ぬまで人気があって
死ぬまでかっこいい人間でいられます
本当に役に立つ人の体形は誰も気にしません
チャッターリマニビッケサンガワットにカタマリチャッタリダーナペイアバジャンアッタティリアンサマナタイマニコビッケチャッタリサンガワット
これ世間の役に立つ道
社会に貢献する項目は 4つです
1 施し  2 愛護  3 有意義な生き方というんですね
4 平等 簡単でしょ これで役に立つんです
お釈迦様に言われるんだから
それ 5つはありませんし 3
で済むわけでもありません
だから私は言ったの 人類の生命の役に立つ人間になりましょう
それが一番最高なかっこいい姿だよと
形ではありません それで
1 は施しっていう単語なんですけど
ダーナっていうのは 自分の能力やいろいろなものをみんなにも分けてあげることなんですよ
この分けることというのはとても大事なことなんです
それでコネクションが成り立つんです
公園でベンチでご飯食べる時は
いくら区役所の人々がゴチャゴチャ言ったっても
ちょこっと何か取りたいハートたちにカラスにあげちゃえば
そのカラス 自分と関係が成り立ってますよ
そのカラスはいい人だと見ているんです
人間を見る頭いいんだから
もうよく覚えてます だから何か自分を持ってるものをね
何かあげて 例えばよく喉がきれい
声がきれいな人がいて
ちょこちょこ誰かにちょっと歌ってあげたりしちゃうと
それも施しなんですよ
そうすると それでコネクションが成り立ってますよ
だからこの何でもいいんですよ
自分にできることは まあちょっとみんなにも見せて
それで貢献してあげて
それで人間関係を築く
それで自分は役に立っているということになるんです
そういうわけで これ施しがないと世界は成り立たないんです
人のことはどうでもいいんだよと思っちゃうともう生きることできないんです
いつでも自分の生き方で周りに役に立つようにすることが施しというんですね
これ愛語 2番目 これはペイアワッジというんですね
言葉がやっぱり気をつけた方がいいんです
ただ喋っただけではダメなんです
なんで喋るんですかね
我々は それ忘れてはならんです
私は喋るということは
私は何かアイデアを他の人々に伝えるためなんですよ
そこが滑らかに優しく伝えることなんです
だからそうすると もう話はこちら一方的に喋るんだけど
みんなに嫌われるとコミュニケーションが切られているんです
嫌われているんです もうとにかく
それがかっこいいんじゃないんです
だから大事なことを喋るし
また聞いていられるし
とても柔らかい言葉で楽しく面白く言ってくれるんだと
そうなってくると そこは愛語なんですね
で 一人一人が戒める場合は
私は自分の言葉で人の心には傷つかないようにするぞということを気をつけておけば
もうたちまち人気者なんです
言葉で人を傷つけない
たまに時々怒鳴らなくちゃいけないし
しつけしなくちゃいけないし
厳しいこと言わない いろんなことを条件が出てきますよ
いかなる場合でも 傷つくことさえはやめますと
気を付ければ同時に自分の頭も良くなっちゃいます
もう人気者なんです  3番目は有意義な生き方というね
アッタチャリア アッタチャリア
有意義であること それで自分が無駄な生き方はしない
人にもそういう生き方を
教えたりアドバイスしたりする
4番目 平等ということ
これはすごい大事なことで
人間というのはもう極限に差別意識なんですね
我々の知識はもう差別するようにできているんですよ
いつでももうすぐ差別感で物事を見ているんです
あの人はかっこ悪いとか
あの人の言葉柄っぽいとかね
あの人はもうすごい背が短いとかね
で こういう風に区別することで差別になるんですね
脳がデータを記録する場合も
この区別でデータ記録するんですよ A
とBと何が違いますか？ということで記憶するんですよ
だから記憶能力も結局危ないんです
例えば2人の顔を見て
我々はすぐまた思い出せるでしょうに
だから無意識的に脳が Aさんと顔と B さんの顔は記録するんですけど
この引き算で何が違いますかと記録しているんです
それは区別というんです
この区別が差別になっちゃうんです
差別になるのは評価するときなんです
例えば A さんの面が長くて
B さんが丸顔だよと脳が記録する
それで評価する 面長い人の方がかっこいいと
それから差別なんです
かっこいい悪いで ただ長いだけ
ただ丸いだけっていう風に
この人は四角いと そういう風に記録すると差別はないんです
だから差別なく区別だけやる人はすごい頭がいいんです
差別入っちゃうと頭が悪くなるんです
だから人間にはすごい能力がありますよ
知識 能力 記憶能力もものすごい抜群があります
が もう 2時半 もう 1時間前
喋ったものはもうとっくに忘れているというね
どう？どういうことでしょうかと
なんで記憶力がそんなに弱いんでしょうかと
どんな人間もすごい記憶能力があります
記憶能力をすごく向上したければ
心から差別ということはもうきれいさっぱり消さなくちゃいけないんです
復活できないように削除しなくちゃいけないんです
区別は自然法則でどうしようもないんです
区別がないと生きていられませんだからね
例えば私はこのジュースだと思ってマイクロフォンを取って飲もうと思ったっても
話にならんでしょうに
だからちゃんと区別する
これがマイクロフォンで飲むものはじゃなくて
これがジュースで飲むものであると
そちらには  この場合はあまり差別感入りませんだけど
我々は人間関係では 生命関係ではもう差別という評価入っちゃうんですね
それやめてほしい それやめちゃうと頭がものすごくよくなっちゃうし
誰にも嫌われないんです
みんなに好かれるんです
差別ない人っていうのは
もう差別の量がね 減れば減るほど
周りからもうすごく好かれるんです
一人一人生命が自分を馬鹿にして欲しくないんです
余計に評価するのは迷惑やと思っちゃうんです
やばいと 我々なんとなく水のごとく
空気のごとく お互い仲良くしたいんです
たとえ顔のしわがあったって
しわ言われて欲しくないんです
しわがあって あのね このしわにはこういう薬を塗った方がいいんですよとか言ってもいいんですよ
あんたね しわがあるでしょうと言っちゃうと
これ差別なんですよ だから同じことを差別なく親切に言える
差別でも言える 差別で言われたらものすごい悪い結果になっちゃうんです
例えば足が 足が短い人が高いところにあるものを取ろうとする
何あんた足が短いんだからこれ取れるわけない
それ差別でしょうに そうではなくて
あのね 足が短い 何かに乗ってくださいよと
もう取れますよと言うと
本人の足が短いことは別に差別していなく
普通の事実として だからそこで嫌な気分にはなりません
そういうわけで このちょこっと心整理することで
私たちの差別を一切消すことはできるんです
それでたちまち素晴らしい世界が現れるんですよ
もう頭が良くなるわ 物は覚えられるわ
みんなに好かれるわ 動物たちにも好かれますよ
差別が消えちゃうと ペットなんか自分が飼っていると思っちゃうと
あんまりいい関係になりません
もう対等に見てみると
結構お互い様は自由で楽しいんですよ
そういうことで すごい大事なこと
平等ということ で 専門用語はありますよ
こういうものにはね 今日は使ってないんです
すごいわかりやすい単語にしたんで
なぜならばやってほしいんです
これには利他とありますし
これは同治と言うんですけどね
同治ってなんかわからないしね
で これは布施で まあ相合相合なんですけどね
だから漢文はもうどうでもいいんですけど
実際これは漢文でこのもう太鼓を叩きながら唱えるものじゃないんです
ブッダの教えは すごい具体的なマニュアルようなものなんです
ですから やらなくちゃいけないんですよ
というわけで 我々にはたったこの4つを守ることで
世界一かっこいい人間にはなります
エーテーコーサンガハーローケ
ラタッサニーワヤーエトーエーテーサンガハーナースーナマタープッタカーラナ
えーと ラベーテマーナンプージャンワーピターワープッタカーラナ
車の車軸のごとく この4つは世に貢献という
で 世界は車に例えて お釈迦様は車の車軸というものがありましてね
古い車イメージしてください
現代の高価な車じゃなくて
で この車軸があって そちらに車輪がつけてるんです
この4つはね 世間に貢献ということになる
それ 車軸と同じだよと
壊れちゃうと車でなくなっちゃいます
ですから 親と子がなくなっちゃいますよと
何するかわからなくなるんだよと
父と子がわからなくなっちゃいますよと
世間道徳も何もなくなってむちゃくちゃになりますよと
そういうわけで 母親が子供に対しても
この4つの貢献しなくちゃいかな
母親が子供に4つの貢献すると
子供も同じ4つの貢献は母親に対する
父親と子供も同じことで
会社と部下も同じことで
人間関係で世間ではこれが貢献という一言葉なんです
貢献といったっても中身は4つ
ヤスマーチャサンガハーエーテーサマウィッカンティパンディタタスマーマハッタンパップンティーパーサンサーチャバワンティテー
したがって 理性のある人はこの4つの項目を大事にする
彼らは大繁栄する また
世に褒め称えられることにもなるということは
かっこいいということなんです
これで大繁栄するんだよと
施しと愛号と有意義な生き方と
4番目平等 たったその 4つで希望は全部叶いますよ
誰でも商売は繁盛したいし
みんなに良く思われてほしいし
幸福で生きていきたいし
長生きしたいし 敵は嫌でしょうし
人間思うものは何でも叶えられます
その方法があります ただ
思っただけでお祈りしただけでは得られません
そこで金持ちになると
金は金は逃げるもんだから
そんなことではなくて
人間として成功したいと思えば
この 4つを守ることなんですね
大繁栄しますよと うん